[Music]  your parents tell me you were born with  unique condition most beautiful baby  I've ever seen accidentally kill people  I'm sorry I don't follow  when people see me you accidentally  assault people with your face yeah it's  strange it is weird  [Music]  what are you doing it's kind of the  middle of something you should probably  find a higher bridge wait what wait what  you're leaving  you at least get her last name was she  hot  I have to tell you I was born with a  face face when people see me they don't  have you ever thought about if your life  for a movie what song they would use in  a montage it's for one of those moments  where your life derails here and all you  hear is this  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  oh my god I tried to tell him damn it  max  you  [Music]  you